And now, for you, Scoutmaster.
So listen, I've been doing a little research, and I think Santa Claus might be a Scoutmaster.
He has a beard. A lot of Scoutmasters have beards.
He always wears the same thing.
I mean, when do you not see him in the same clothes?
He drives this old, beat-up vehicle that's been around for years.
I mean, he's had it for ages.
And finally, his clothes are all tarnished with ashes and soot.
You know, I think I might be on the side.
Hey, this is podcast number 47.
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
So, the last podcast, number 46.
We talked about the process of Scouting.
Larry Geiger sent this in.
He said,
Great show. Just a process.
Well, it sounds so simple.
Yeah.
Yep.
So simple.
Scouts don't behave like a product.
That's classic.
You'll know that it's working when a mom comes to you and says,
What happened to my little boy?
He's been so mature and grown up since she started Scouting.
Yeah.
That's...
And I should say, if you get on the blog,
take a look at Larry's comment there,
especially if you're interested in Courts of Honor,
because Larry has some good notes about that.
From Phil,
Clark,
I anxiously await my drive home from work each Monday,
as I know I'll be able to listen to your podcast on my long commute.
Thanks so much for all the time and efforts you put into the show.
I use them in my own unit and share them with others.
I plan on burning a bunch of shows to your CD
and handing them out at my next roundtable.
Wow.
Well, Phil, thank you.
CDs at the roundtable.
That's a good idea.
Might not be very popular after you've handed those out, but...
Oh, well.
I'm sure it'll work out for you.
A couple of new reviews over on iTunes,
and I just wanted to thank Jim and Jaluz for leaving reviews.
Jim says that my jokes are not world-class comedy,
and I'm glad he pointed that out,
because the package on the jokes,
when I bought them,
had a label,
and it said world-class comedy,
and I am returning them.
So in this podcast and Scout Mastership,
in seven minutes or less,
what is Scout Mastership anyway?
Yeah.
A little talk about that.
Then I've got an email question to answer,
and a post that went on the blog this week
that got several good comments that I wanted to talk about.
So, that's a lot to do.
Let's get started, shall we?
Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less.
You know, whenever I type the word Scout Mastership
into my computer,
the spell checker underlines it in red.
It's just not a common term, is it?
Scout Mastership.
My best guess is that it was probably coined by Baden-Powell
in the title of his little booklet,
Aids to Scout Mastership.
Dictionaries don't recognize that word.
But Scout Mastership, the word,
I like it because I think it embodies an important concept
that differentiates the work of Scouting in general,
and Scout Masters in particular,
from other forms of leadership and administration and management.
You know, we can find some inspiration and practical advice
in the study of business management
and, you know, leadership books and things like that.
And we can certainly adapt a lot of those concepts
into the unique practice of Scout Mastership.
But as we've talked about before,
we're not responsible for the production of a product
or the management of easily quantified numerical goals.
And we're not charged with administering a program
or maintaining a set of standards.
I think Scout Mastership has elements of teaching
and parenting and mentoring and leading and managing
and administering,
yet it defies definition
of any one of those single fields.
The term Scout Mastership sets us apart
and sets the role apart as a pretty unique endeavor.
Scout Masters mentor Scouts through a variety of experiences
in such a way that they learn for themselves
and they weave together all the various influences in their lives.
We're given a more general inspiration as Scout Masters
than a lot of specific directions.
And purposefully so,
because each one of us will have a slightly different way
of carrying out the work.
A great revelation for Scout Masters
is the discovery that there's no
universally adaptable step-by-step plan for scouting,
but rather well-expressed
yet potentially frustrating generalizations.
Here's an example.
Is every Eagle Scout identical in character
and deportment to every other Eagle Scout?
Does every troop operate under a universal,
specific method of administration?
Well, you can say yes,
but you know everybody's going to handle it
a little bit differently.
Is every Scout equally talented?
Do they all share the same disposition and outlook?
Well, there's a lot of common points,
but every single one of them is different.
I think what might help understand this
is something expressed by the diplomat,
Carl Schurz.
He said,
Ideals are like stars.
You will not succeed in touching them with your hands,
but like the seafaring man
on the ocean desert of waters.
You choose them as your guides,
and following them you reach your destiny.
This reminds me of a story of
some years ago
when I was on the Chesapeake Bay
and we were steering a replica
of a 17th century ship,
the Half Moon,
the Henry Hudson ship.
down from Wilmington, Delaware,
down to Washington, D.C.
Now, this ship didn't have a steering wheel
like most ships.
It didn't have a helm
like you're familiar with seeing.
It had this kind of devilish,
old, primitive device
attached to the rudder
called a whip stave.
And the steersman
stands in this little doghouse
on the after deck
with no view of the water at all.
I mean,
you really,
you can't see
what's ahead of you.
You can't see what's beside you.
And the directions
have to be relayed
by an officer
conning the ship
above the doghouse
to the steersman
who, you know,
will be watching a compass
and swings the whip stave around
to adjust the course.
It's not an easy system.
You can tell
why ships are not built today
with whip staves.
And it's not
a system that lends itself
to pinpoint accuracy.
Staying on course
in that ship
was not really about
following a line.
It was occupying a position
in a wide path.
I mean,
ships don't respond quickly.
The con has to anticipate
adjustments to course
far ahead
accounting for currents
and winds
and, you know,
whatever is happening out there.
A skilled mariner
doesn't fight
with the conditions
that he finds.
He learns to integrate them
into the art of steering
his ship.
And scouting is
a lot like that.
It's a wide path
with plenty of room
for course correction
and plenty of allowance
for leeway.
Scout Mastership
isn't the job
so much as directing
as kind of coaxing
things along.
Not so much
as arriving
at a point
but as traveling,
achieving,
and getting there.
It's not so much
what we end up with
as what we do.
Scout Mastership
integrates the influences
of society
and family
and school
and church
to make decent
human beings
while they're in
one of the most
chaotic periods
of their lives potentially.
We're not
working towards goals.
We're shaping destinies.
Scout music
Help me
Grow them up
for the B.S.A.
Three fingers
salute
There ain't no doubt
about it
I'm gonna jump up
and scream
and shout it
Looking good
in my uniform
Cause baby
I was born
to be a scout
Cause baby
I was born
to be a
Here comes
Scoutmaster
Drive a job
The scout
will be
a little faster
Step on the gas
Are we there yet?
I wanna build a bridge
for my Eagle
Project
Write me a letter
Send it by mail
Email that is folks
And here's an answer
to one of your
emails
So I had this email
from Phil
Phil says
Our troop is only
two years old
and I'm the second
Scoutmaster
in as many years
Our senior patrol leader
is a young star scout
and is one of those
who will do anything
scouting
just for the sake of it
He's a very driven
young man
but lacks the skills
of a true leader
and has not
learned to really
serve his troop
He's a bit on the
bossy side
and he doesn't like it
when things don't
go his way
I went to my
second patrol leader's
council meeting
the other night
Set up a
Scoutmaster chair
off to one side
and so I could
just observe
the happenings
of the patrol
leader's council
and offer some
coaching from the
sidelines
without being
disruptive
I did all the
things you've
talked about
I let the
patrol leader's
council problem
solve
and I quietly
just sat there
and took notes
The problem is
the troop is
relatively new
and the patrol
leader's council
in my opinion
hasn't been
planning programs
that will keep
scouts coming
to meetings
Towards the
end of the
patrol leader's
council
I asked some
leading questions
and talked about
meetings a little
bit
and they talked
about fun and
well structured
meetings that had
a purpose
but then they
proceeded to plan
some really boring
meetings that will
not keep scouts
coming around
They lack
instruction and
purpose or
something exciting
Now the patrol
leader's council
even admits that
this is the case
but they're okay
in settling for
something that
is easy and
boring
What advice
can you offer
me on how
to guide them
into building
a program
that scouts
won't be able
to turn down
for other
activities
Well Phil
from what you're
telling me
everything is
actually going
very well
The key elements
for a successful
troop are in
place
you have a
motivated youth
leadership
and adults
have an
appreciation
for the process
and respect
the autonomy
of the scouts
in the troop
So let's look
at some of the
concerns you
express individually
You say the
meetings lack
instruction and
purpose or
something exciting
Borderman
excitement are
kind of both
matters of
perspective
I think if I
had to sit
through my
troop meetings
as a scout
I would be
pretty bored
but I'm no
longer a teenager
And the things
that I think
are really
fascinating and
interesting and
engaging
they would
bore most of
my scouts
to tears
Sometimes boys
they're not all
that creative
in our eyes
They tend to
do what the
last guy did
Every once in
a while someone
will come up
with a hot
idea but
boys like
routine and
familiarity
to a greater
extent than we
think
I try to
respond
enthusiastically
to the least
little indication
of initiative
and working
along but
remember
it's a trick
of perspective
If you have
60% or more
of your scouts
showing up at
meetings on a
regular basis
you're doing
probably a little
bit better than
most of us
I'd be concerned
if you're seeing
a big downturn
in attendance
over many
many weeks
because you
can't really look
at like the
past three or
four weeks
they're not
enough of a
trend
and I'll tell
you just from
experience
three or four
weeks there can
be a series of
competing events
or convergences of
unusual circumstances
that keep boys
away from
meetings
I've seen
lots of
different reasons
you show up
at a meeting
and you look
around and
there's a
third of the
troop is there
or a quarter
of the troop
is there
and you think
oh my god
we've lost it
and you find
out that
six guys
are out
because they
were out of
school
because there's
some bug
going around
school
or there's
a big football
game or
something is
going on
that they had
a cross
commitment
to
and it's
not necessarily
time to ring
the emergency
bell and change
everything around
so look at it
over a long
time and if
you've got
60% or more
showing up
you're doing
real real good
in my book
you also say
this Phil
our senior patrol
leader is a
young star scout
and he's one of
those who will
do anything
scouting for the
sake of it
okay so he's
pretty motivated
you even say
he's a very
driven young man
but he lacks
the skills of a
true leader
and he hasn't
really learned
to serve his
troop and you
add that he's
a bit on the
bossy side and
he doesn't like
when things don't
go their way
well if he's a
young star scout
you're describing
a boy who's
maybe 13 to
15 years old
and when you're
describing your
senior patrol
leader you're
describing most
boys who are
13 to 15 years
old
yeah
nothing special
going on there
he'll get the
idea
watch for the
slightest little
indication that
he's understood
something and
encourage him
ask questions that
you don't know the
answer to
and this is
important
if you're going
to talk to your
senior patrol
leader and you're
going to see if
you can pull some
information out of
them you're going
to ask questions
that you honestly
don't know the
answer to be
honestly inquisitive
I catch myself
using questions to
coerce a given
response sometimes
and that's
that's not fair
so you want to
check with him
about things that
you honestly don't
know the answer to
and it might
might give you a
real in on what
he's thinking and
what he's doing and
help you coach him
along
there's a couple
other things that
are important
this is a pretty
young troop
you say you're only
two years old
you're a new
scoutmaster
and there's
already been a
change of
scoutmasters in
this troop
and you know
regardless of
what the last
guy did
he was the
guy and now
you're the
new guy
and this is
your second
patrol leaders
council meeting
and I know
you're anxious
to do the
right thing
and you seem
to be headed
in the right
direction
so I'm going
to encourage
you to be a
little more
patient with
yourself
and your
scouts
troop
it takes
months and
years for
some of these
things to prove
themselves to you
and to your
scouts
you'll look
back and see
it was all
worth it
and you'll
also see
that it
didn't happen
quite as
quickly as
you would
have liked
and there
were times
when your
data with
any of it
would work
at all
in the end
you got to
trust the
process
even in the
absence of
evidence that
it's succeeding
in short you
have to have
faith in what
you're doing
really
as soon as
your youth
leaders that
you have
right now
begin to get
experienced and
mature and they
show some real
competence and
understanding of
the job
guess what's
going to
happen next
they're going
to move on
and it's going
to start all
over again
it's a great
process and
once you've been
through it a
couple of times
you'll have a
lot of confidence
and faith in
what you're doing
be a little more
patient and I
think things are
going to work
out fine
have you ever
wandered lonely
through the
woods
everything that
feels just as
it should
you're part of
a life there
something good
if you've ever
wandered lonely
through the
woods
the founder of
scouting
Baden Powell
once said
this
scouting is a
movement because
it moves forward
as soon as it
stops moving
it becomes an
organization
and really
isn't scouting
I think there's
a relationship
between the
creative visionary
force and the
great ideas
behind scouting
and the formal
framework that
facilitates their
application and
sometimes it's not
an easy relationship
in scouting we
have this vision
these ideas that
define scouting
and then we have
policies and
procedures and
an organizational
framework to put
this all together
we make a mistake
if we look on the
policies as being
real restrictive
and chafing
and difficult
and we
make we
equally make a
mistake if we
look on the
policies as being
the be-all and
end-all of
scouting
I don't think
that they're
either
every once in a
while you run
against a policy
or procedure that
you find maybe
distasteful or
difficult
and unfortunately
sometimes we
in training
overemphasize
policy and
procedure
procedure we
can't really
comprehend the
vision of
scouting by just
knowing policies
it's really the
other way around
we have to catch
the vision for
those policies and
procedures to make
any sense we need
an organization we
need definition we
need guidance but
we need a vision and
inspiration of a
movement to enliven
those things now
when this post hit
Facebook I got three
very interesting
comments David said
people with scouting
in their hearts use
policy to support the
scouting vision people
with scouting in their
heads use policy to
support their own
vision the first kind
use it as an enabler
or facilitator the
latter use it as an
opportunity for
control well that was
very well put David
very well put Greg
said this here here
I find some of the
adults I encounter in
scouting to be overly
focused on the
policies that seems to
be what they most
enjoy about the
program I know we've
all encountered them
but policies are not
an end in themselves
too many of us think
that they are and
finally Timothy said
a lot of adults seem
to forget it's boy
scouts not adult
scouts so let's stay
with the vision let's
keep with the vision
and let the vision
inform the policies and
not another way not the
other way around
well thanks for
listening to this
edition of the
scoutmaster podcast
you can read the
scoutmaster blog at
scoutmaster.typepad.com
and you can follow us at
scoutmaster blog on
facebook and scoutmaster
cg on twitter
you can subscribe to the
scoutmaster podcast on
itunes and when you do
feel free to leave a
comment or a review or
a rating you can email
me clarkgreen with your
comments and questions
at clarkgreen at gmail.com
that's c-l-a-r-k-e-g-r-e-e-n
at gmail.com
the scoutmaster blog and the
scoutmaster podcast are not
official publications of the
boy scouts of america nor are
they endorsed or sponsored by
the boy scouts of america
nope it's just me talking
into a microphone trying to
lend a hand to scout leaders
and perhaps have a bit of
fun along the way even
though i i don't have any
world-class comedy hey bonus
joke coming up in a moment
how many surrealists does it take to change a light bulb how many
surrealists does it take to change a light bulb the answer fish
it's uh the holiday season stop in at the blog i have uh three lists of uh possible gifts for scouters scout leaders scout masters assistant scout masters whomever somebody interested in scouting i've got a list of classic books that i i really love some books that have been
featured here on the scoutmaster podcast and uh some gear so stop by take a look
before we leave you we want to hear from our founder sir robert baden powell
sir robert
good luck to you and good camping
thank you sir
until next time
you